you can actually control and own your
money
you can actually have your money right
you don't how else you're going to have
it in cash and then you've got to deal
with the inflation how difficult is it
to move serious cash I'm I had to send
it's about four years ago I sent
nine hundred thousand dollars to Qatar
for a completely legal reason why I had
to buy one to buy a property guitar so I
was involved in the purchasing my
apartment guitar do you the back flips
the paperwork the legal nightmare I
swear to God I was putting a travel list
because for about a year after that I'll
stop to every airport just for a bank
transfer right no problem with Bitcoin
no problem so it fixes a whole bunch of
problems cryptocurrencies it certainly
does and I think a lot of people who are
Forward Thinking and believe the things
I believe in it's the only logical
conclusion what else you can do trust a
bank you trust them there's nothing else
to do with it I'm actually at the point
where although I don't I do own quite a
lot of property I don't want any more
and I keep getting offered nice property
deals and Tristan's like should we buy
this it's like no I don't even trust the
Romanian government or the Russian
government I property in Moscow I don't
even trust the government anymore I
don't even want a property because if I
piss the government off they're just
gonna take it I don't own it they say
you own it until you annoy the
government then you don't own it right
so I don't even want property anymore
I'm going full crazy Mr blockchain now
because it's the only time I feel like I
have control over things and we're
losing control at such a rapid rate I'm
trying to stay ahead of the curve I
don't believe people saying oh I'll just
buy a house and it's my little house
it's not your little house you'll see
how quickly they'll take your little
house from you look what they've done so
far they're taking your business from
you you think they want to take your
little house people aren't people are
not scared enough of the right things
they're scared of Corona they should be
scared of what the government did to
them in the name of Corona that's what
they should be but people aren't logical
people aren't logical people have low
IQs they're slaves and they're too busy
preoccupied with racism and also the
garbage to keep them split so they can't
all get together for five seconds and
start thinking wait
this is [ __ ] you remember the big
Bitcoin crash five thousand four hundred
dollars at the beginning of this Corona
thing I'm gonna really really tanked
everyone say it's over all this crap I
put a tweet up that I still retweet to
this day saying you're all [ __ ]
bitcoin's coming back I think I said I'm
buying 600 000 today and you'll we can
talk when it's a 8 000 I think I said
that so I turned 600 Grand to like 12
million dollars
because I I had cash in a bank and when
everything hit the fan the first thing I
thought was I don't want cash
I want something else give me an asset
okay how can I get an asset that the
government can't take Bitcoin